la economía de eeuu comenzó el año con
el crecimiento esa es la noticia con la
que abrimos esta sección de economía y
para comentarlo está con nosotros daniel
hablando con daniela muy buenas noches
eeuu va por buen camino hola santiago
buenas noches así parece después el plan
de estímulos por 19 billones de dólares
aprobado por el congreso disparó el
consumo en el primer trimestre del año
eso hizo que la economía creciera 6,4
por ciento frente al mismo trimestre del
año pasado y 1,6 por ciento en
comparación con el trimestre anterior
uno de los datos santiago en los que más
se fijan los analistas para medir la
salud de la economía es el desempleo y
muestra de las recuperaciones que las
peticiones de subsidios cayeron de nuevo
hasta los 553 mil en la última semana
hace un año en marzo llegaron a un pico
máximo histórico de 68 millones pero
todavía no llega a los niveles pre
pandemia que era de 210 mil peticiones
semanales hay quienes creen sin embargo
que el tema de subsidio no refleja
exactamente la realidad escuchemos
y también son elegibles para los
subsidios los van a recolectar por el
mayor tiempo posible dada la naturaleza
de esos beneficios por desempleo la
gente puede decir me siento incómodo
yendo a trabajar pues no tengo que
hacerlo y si me pagan más dinero por
desempleo del que obtendría si volviera
a la oficina porque debería volver
hablemos ahora de colombia porque ya se
conoce allí el impacto que ha tenido la
pandemia de kobe 19 en los indicadores
de pobreza de ese país
santiago y lo voy a conocer el
departamento nacional de estadística que
reveló que en todo 2020 un total de 35
millones de personas entraron en
situación de pobreza y otros 28 millones
de personas ingresaron a la pobreza
extrema en términos porcentuales en 2019
la pobreza afectaba al 35 7 por ciento
de la población y en 2020 la cifra ya
iba en cuatro de cada diez ciudadanos en
pobreza extrema ocurrió algo parecido
santiago antes de la pandemia era menos
del 10% de la población ahora es el 15,1
por ciento
en resumen de la situación al cierre de
un difícil 2020 colombia que es un país
de 50 millones
de habitantes tenía 21 millones de
personas pobres y a 75 millones no les
alcanza ni siquiera para suplir su
canasta básica de alimentos difícil la
situación allí y precisamente europa
ante este panorama en américa latina
está pidiendo más ayuda económica para
colaborarle a los países
latinoamericanos si el parlamento
europeo aprobó una resolución no
vinculante en la que pide a la unión
europea ya sus estados miembros que
desplieguen más fondos de solidaridad
para latinoamérica esta es la región
como sabemos más afectada económicamente
por la pandemia y hasta el momento dice
la comisaria europea de servicios
financieros se han aprobado recursos por
4 mil 200 millones de euros
para américa latina y el caribe también
asegura que se han garantizado 38
millones de vacunas a 30 países a través
del mecanismo
kóvacs de vacunación daniela van a subir
los precios mundiales de los productos
básicos más sí señor mucho más ésta es
una alerta por lo menos que lanza las
grandes multinacionales como procter and
gamble kimberly clark
estas advirtieron que se avecinan
grandes incrementos en los precios de
muchos de sus productos a medida que
aumentan los costos de las materias
primas ponga atención a este dato entre
los más afectados está el papel
higiénico los productos para cuidado de
bebés las bebidas gaseosas y muchos
otros productos de uso diario la razón
es que el consumo está subiendo y no hay
suficiente oferta además ha habido
fuertes alzas en materias primas como el
básico el papel el azúcar y los cereales
las empresas también están pagando más
por el transporte ya que el precio del
petróleo se está acercando a los 70
dólares y eso afecta directamente a los
combustibles
hay que seguir apretándose el cinturón
hablemos ahora de los indicadores 'wall
street' en 0 positivo en medio de buenos
resultados financieros de amazon que
triplicó sus beneficios y 'twitter' que
volvió a ganar en el primer trimestre
récord para el estándar en pues las
acciones europeas cerraron a la baja a
pesar de que los bancos de la zona
mostraron sólidas ganancias y cierra sin
grandes movimientos en américa latina
chile sigue en rojo por el temor a una
desfinanciación de las
administradores de fondos de pensiones y
para el cierre la cifra del día las
grandes empresas siguen presentando
resultados del primer trimestre el turno
y santiago es para automotrices fort
reporta una inesperada ganancia de 3 mil
300 millones de dólares frente a
pérdidas del año pasado
y tesla subió más de 2600 por ciento su
ganancia pasó de apenas 16 millones el
primer trimestre del año pasado a 438
millones en el comienzo de 2021 siempre
haremos que se benefician con la crisis
muchas gracias daniela es todo por el
momento en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]